- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk a little
bit about mutations,
and I wanna apologize ahead of time.
My voice is a little strange today.
I rode more roller coasters
than I thought I would yesterday,
and I screamed a little bit.
But anyway, (chuckles)
what we see right over here
is what's often known as the
central dogma of biology.
It explains how we go from
information in our DNA,
which is really sequences of nucleotides,
genes are segments of our DNA
that code for specific things.
So we see these nucleotides,
which we denote with A, C, Gs, and Ts.
And every three of them,
that's known as a codon,
and for every three of them,
it's associated with an amino acid.
And in other future parts
of your biology education,
you'll go into more depth
on the molecular
structures of amino acids.
But what you need to know now
is the amino acids are
essentially strung together.
And then they create proteins.
And proteins have all sorts
of functions in your body.
To a large degree, they make you, you.
They construct what you are.
So this is a simplified version
of how we go from DNA,
to you, to some degree.
Now, mutations, as you might know,
even when you watch some movies,
these are changes in DNA.
You might have seen superheroes
be exposed to radiation
or some type of chemical,
and then they get mutations,
and then all of a sudden they have powers.
Well, we don't know
about too many mutations
that create the ability to
fly or to stick to walls.
But mutations are a way that
we get new genetic information
in the gene pool.
Now you might be saying,
wait, I already know
about sexual reproduction.
Sexual reproduction creates variation.
And that's true.
Sexual reproduction creates variation
but it really just
shuffles around the genes
and the chromosomes they're on
that exist already inside of a gene pool.
Mutations are actually
changes in the genes.
Now, where do these mutations come from?
Well, there are sometimes
errors when DNA is copied,
but can also happen from
environmental influences,
like radiation or other things.
Now, as you can imagine,
many times, if you were
to just all of a sudden
eliminate some nucleotides,
or if you were to change
them into something else,
that might be harmful.
All of a sudden it might
code for an amino acid here
that does not allow this
protein to function properly.
Sometimes, it can be beneficial.
And that's how we can get new
versions of genes, alleles,
or new genes altogether.
All of a sudden this became that,
this becomes a different amino acid,
maybe this protein functions better.
And then as you can imagine,
sometimes, it doesn't matter at all.
Maybe the different amino acid here
really doesn't change the
structure of this protein.
And in some cases, you can
even change a nucleotide
and it still codes for
the same amino acid.